enfrentamientos en la capital niamey
entre las fuerzas de seguridad y los
partidarios del candidato de la
oposición mahaman usman que se declara
ganador de la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales las protestas
que han dejado al menos dos muertos
también se han desatado en la ciudad de
dos o donde a principios de esta semana
se incendió la oficina de un partido
progubernamental el gobierno culpa a
hama amadou por los disturbios el líder
de la oposición no pudo presentarse a
las elecciones presidenciales pero apoya
a mahamat guzmán el jueves el ministro
del interior de níger dijo que las
fuerzas de seguridad habían detenido a
más de 400 personas un grupo que incluía
a políticos han detenido a varios de
ellos hoy lo principal responsable y se
está buscando el principal responsable
pero como siempre huyó de coma sin él en
fin
con el telón de fondo de las protestas
unos desconocidos incendiaron varias
viviendas entre ellas la de un veterano
periodista de radio france
internationale un ataque que el estado
atribuye a la oposición con la salida
del presidente y su fuma amaiur tras
diez años en el mandato níger se
encuentro en medio de su primera
transición de poder elegida desde la
independencia y mientras la comisión
electoral del país dice que la votación
la ganó mohamed bazum el ex ministro del
interior la oposición impugnó al
resultado
y sumamos el régimen del señor hizo fue
mahamadou quiere confiscar sin
escrúpulos la voluntad del pueblo que se
ha expresado mayoritariamente a mi favor
en la segunda vuelta
los observadores de la comunidad
económica de estados de áfrica
occidental han dicho que las elecciones
se han celebrado en condiciones libres
junto con naciones unidas la unión
regional ha condenado la violencia y ha
instado a todas las partes a dar
muestras de contención